welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host the deaf knight of back with
your weekly update on the Batman every
week at the same bat-time same
bat-channel I'm gonna be doing updates
on the movie and this week we've had a
lot of pre-production hints as to what's
going on throughout this video we'll be
going over the new bat suit and
Batmobile details what Colin Farrell is
said about the script and some updates
to the cast list there may be some
spoilers here so if you don't want
anything potentially rude about the
movie then I highly suggest that you
turn off now make sure you subscribe to
the channel to never miss an update like
this and without the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking the
video now let's get into our breakdown
of the Batman okay so we have a lot of
exciting updates this week on the
Batsuit that really give the portrayal
of how it will be last week we discussed
how Lieber may show had shared what look
like concept art of the suit and this
was very akin to his design from the
comics this week we have a lot more
information to add on top of that and it
really sounds like the suit is gonna be
something special
according to Batman on film we will be
getting our first glimpse at both the
bat suit and Batmobile very shortly and
with filming due to start properly in
Glasgow in February it looks highly
likely that we won't have to wait much
longer than a month
if DC was smart they'd drop the bat suit
and Batmobile and birds of prey so
people actually cared about the movie
but yeah I don't think they're gonna I'm
just playing Harley yeah you know I love
you the website indicates that the new
bat suit won't be like anything that has
appeared in any Batman movie ever
however before you think it's probably
just a kid wearing their hood over the
head and running around the playground
the producers did say that it will be in
line with what you would expect to see
Batman wearing the report states that
unlike the Dark Knight suit which was
made predominantly by Lucius Fox this
time round a Bruce Wayne will be solely
responsible for the suit that also means
you'll probably be able to pee in it
Christian Bale would be proud apparently
the new look won't have all of the
gadgetry and high-tech features of a
wine industry costume and it will be
something that he made himself the
Bellagio suit does sort of feature this
aesthetic it does look like something
that you could build if you had the
resources the Batman year one suit was
also very sim
this and with it being the start of a
new trilogy it does make a lot of sense
this sounds like it's gonna be a lot
more comic-book accurate and I'm very
hype for it at the moment there are
rumors that it may be released on
Valentine's Day but we really don't know
so yeah take that with a pinch of salt
as for the Batmobile if you checked out
last week's episode you'll know that we
said the Batmobile might be in line with
a sports car
however we now have a new details on
this from website Batman on film and it
says that though the car will be toned
back it will be more akin to a muscle
car similar to the bat suit there will
be no outside tech for the car and there
will have its own upgrades these will be
cobbled together by Wayne Wayne is a
keen mechanic as we saw in films like
Batman Returns and this is littered
throughout the comic books so yeah it's
very in line with those hopefully it has
a cup holder that comes in black as it
doesn't look like the car is going to be
something that will be used for military
applications
last week we confirmed that ash dog was
working on the car and he actually
posted some very interesting images on
Instagram that teased what it could look
like the following post comes from his
account and yeah he pretty much confirms
that it will be a muscle car with this
note on top of this he also posted a
photo of a car that it looks very
interesting and yeah I am kind of
drawing conclusions here however it does
line up with a lot of things this is the
c7 ex and though it isn't a muscle car
it does look like something that Batman
would look good in he says he has a
couple of other cars in the process that
he's working on so this could be a
design for another film but just from
the look of it it does seem like
something that Caped Crusader would
drive the Batcave Twitter account posted
some of ash Thorpe's car designs along
side with the Liebherr maysha Batmobile
and I have to say they all look in line
with one another and something that the
character would look great driving
around in so that's the big updates on
the Batsuit in Batmobile
and I feel like we've had to wait
forever I love poring over these details
but yeah hopefully it's not too long
before we see them we've also had some
updated cast news and con o'neill has
been added to the IMDB cast list as
chief mackenzie brock in addition to
this we also know who the Commissioner
of Gotham will be and
this kind of confirms that Gordon will
still be a lower-ranking officer so it
has been reported that Alex ferns will
be playing Commissioner Pete Savage Alex
ferns recently featured in Chernobyl but
if you like me a 90s baby that grew up
in the UK and chances are you know him
from EastEnders and what he did to
little Moe will never forgive you Trevor
Batman's gonna get you for this again
this might mean that Gordon is the
captain and that he has to work with the
Batman to rise up through the ranks and
restore order to Gotham before we get
into the rest of the video I just want
to let you know we're giving away a free
copy of dr. sleep to one random
subscriber all you have to do to be in
with the chance of winning is like the
video subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on the updates in the
comments section below the winners gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of
February in the subtly shift out from
then to ever gets the prize it's the
best of luck to everyone who takes part
now Colin Farrell had a big interview
this week that cleared up a lot of
things I'm gonna play a clip from it in
just a second but there's actually a
correction we need to make beforehand so
last week we reported that someone that
looked like Farrell had been seen on set
but this turned out to just be a dude
with an umbrella
there was also an image of Farrell with
bleach hair and this made us think that
he was leaning into the emperor penguin
look but this is later been debunked is
something that he just does when to
celebrate basically finishing a movie so
yeah don't say we don't admit it when
we're wrong we're proud to say we're
idiots at this channel suppose the image
did push Reeves to confirm that Ferrell
was the penguin so I guess it could be
good to be stupid I don't know anyway
fowl was promoting the gentlemen and
here's the clip from the interview but
the penguin it surprises me that you are
the penguin because usually the penguin
is a short fat person yeah but I have
some time to eat and how much time
before you start shooting this three
weeks but I'd like to have a good barber
with my black card yeah yeah
well you actually put a don't know I'm
still in the process of talking to Matt
Reeves who's the director who wrote this
Grafton Road really like really
beautiful dark moving script really
gorgeous you read the whole thing
already yeah yeah with a chain and you
know around my arm and cryogenically
frozen script it's all very right rush
but it's a really beautiful script that
he wrote he has a real love for it Matt
so we're still in the process is just
finishing designing the aesthetic Robert
Pattinson is Batman Patterson's patent
on Jeffrey Wright Dano is the Riddler
yeah Jeffrey writes in there zoe kravitz
is that woman yeah yeah really cool
villain great he'll cast a lot of
villains yeah yeah kids are tired to be
playing a film are they really add a
comment bars but yeah but they get
action figures you'll be in it and maybe
they'll learn the route for the villains
you know I think of that man I just used
the opportunity to tell him what a good
guy I wasn't real life yeah
daddy's gonna have action figures that's
just the sentence every father has ever
wanted to share with their chair I try
to use that on Dumbo but they kinda had
gone past
Dumbo Danny DeVito give his penguin
blessing to you know someone sent me a
link that he thought he did yeah we did
he did it over the Internet
yeah it's very personal he did he said
he'd someone sent me a link and he said
just that I was G's an actor or
something I don't know but but that
everyone should be able to experience
anything and all that kind of good stuff
yeah but the gentleman opens in theaters
on Friday Colin Farrell everybody so
it's going to be a dark and beautiful
script this could mean a lot of things
but when I think of dark and beautiful
with Batman my mind jumps to the long
Halloween it's pretty much the Godfather
of comics and the iconography of the
book is outstanding they use silhouette
incredibly effectively in it and it's
also a Taylor family it's one of the
best Batman books ever written and the
movie itself is apparently based upon
its yeah this all kind of ties in with
it it's brilliant that Danny DeVito also
gave His blessing and he pretty much
carved out one of the most iconic
versions of the character
put de film also ferrell has confirmed
he's putting on weight so yeah pretty
much scrap all of that emperor penguin
stuff
either way though these updates are
pretty minor they do get me incredibly
excited for the film can't wait to see
what new releases we get next week and
yet thanks for sticking with me and next
week I'll see you same bat-time same
bat-channel
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on these updates and if you're
excited for the movie comment below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of last week which is going to
be linked at the end you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate it and it goes a
long way you can get access to content
early and also suggest video topics and
breakdowns if you want to come chat to
us after the video then follow us at
definition whitey or click the discord
link in the description below this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thank you
for taking the time to watch this I've
been definition you've been the best
I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]